l'étape champêtre les restos ferme on la
cote les gens sont prêts à se déplacer
loin des grands centres si la qualité et
la beauté des lieux sont au rendez-vous
et si on vous offre en plus un produit
rare ça lui rend sûrement pas
alors le cube juste au fond c'est la
terrine d'agneau à la canneberge juste
devant les petits cubes c'est notre pâté
de fois et on a gagné des prix avec ce
pote et de l'eau ce que vous voyez là
c'est un plateau de charcuterie d'agneau
mais c'est aussi le résultat de 100 ans
de labeur on est à Saint-Nazaire au lac
Saint-Jean c'est ici que mes
grands-parents il y a 100 ans se sont
installés et ont élevé leurs enfants par
la suite c'est mon père Julien qui a
repris les reines de la ferme familiale
pour en faire une production Ovide à
l'époque dans les années 60 on était
dans la période où l'agneau était avait
mauvaise presse c'était le moins
populaire
trois générations plus tard Myriam et
son frère Dany sont devenus les fiers
gardiens des terres agricoles familiales
j'ai 47 heures j'ai toujours été ici
fait que c'est ma vie c'est ma passion
Dany s'occupe de toute la production au
champ la production forestière l'élevage
du troupeau et le fourrage et produit
sur nos terres bio pour nourrir nos
animaux toute la production Vienne est
faite dans nos bergeries sur notre ferme
mais là on a beaucoup de d'agneaux qui
sont nés dernièrement qui vont naître
d'un proche et moi c'est qu'on va monter
probablement 1500 têtes le printemps
et moi je m'occupe la restauration de la
transformation et de la mise en marché
tout ça c'est fait ici dans nos
installations on pourrait continuer à
vendre nos agneaux sur le marché et on
aurait le revenu de ça et ça s'arrête
très long mais je pense que si on veut
se démarquer on doit faire la
transformation
si on se promène au Québec on va trouver
d'autres éleveurs qui transforment
l'agneau en charcuterie comme ici à la
bergerie Dupont près de rivières du loup
[Musique]
à sa table champêtre Myriam aime
toujours autant préparer manuellement
ces terrines on peut le faire
mécaniquement moi j'ai pris l'habitude
puis j'aime vraiment le faire avec mes
mains c'est comme un thérapeutique
[Musique]
donc on a le bacon l'agneau le phare des
œufs un petit peu de muscade et les
canneberges puis après ça c'est le
parter dans le bac ce qui est important
c'est de mélanger tous les ingrédients
pour que la protéine devienne un petit
peu plus élastique ce qui va conférer
encore une fois une caractéristique un
petit peu plus
crémeuse une fois que ça c'est fait
reste à la cuire tout simplement
ici à l'orée des champs à la base c'est
une table champêtre certifiée dans les
premières années s'il y avait le corps
des clients qui
osaient goûter à l'agneau c'était quand
même super bien aujourd'hui c'est chose
servir un repas où il y a pas d'agneau
je vais dans ça on peut pas on va se
faire chicaner aussi loin des grands
centres on pourrait penser qu'il est
difficile d'attirer les gourmands mais
les visiteurs sont au rendez-vous si les
produits en valent la peine ce sens est
un chorizo d'agneau et dans le ramequin
blanc c'est de l'agneau confit donc on
met en valeur une pièce moins noble qui
est le collier le coût de l'agneau qu'on
va saumurer et confire au gras d'agneau
et de canards j'ai des petits des petits
croûtons ici j'ai un petit truc merci
beaucoup
c'est bon
on les voit les beaux morceaux
ce qui est important aussi pour moi
c'est de garder le produit le plus à
l'état pur possible donc c'est le
minimum le minimum de nitrate le minimum
d'agent de remplissage possible donc on
a vraiment la viande on a la viande sans
gras il y a pas d'effet de grand bouche
vraiment réussi à saucisse j'ai jamais
mangé de pâté de fois à l'agneau là je
suis très curieuse
ça goûte l'agneau mais c'est ça qui
fantastique c'est que les gens peuvent
se dire c'est un abat ça va être trop
fort en bouche non mais c'est tout
délicat
c'est charcuteries se vendent aussi dans
des épiceries fines ou des bonnes tables
de la région au point où ils ont de la
difficulté à répondre à la demande
c'est ce qu'on fait
on accélère la production écoute garde
tantôt là on a juste fait nos commandes
de cette semaine puis là il manque trois
sortes de charcuterie déjà maintenant on
n'a pas le choix de produire de produire
de la qualité de la quantité si on veut
être capable d'envie qu'est-ce que votre
grand-père dirait si il rentrait ici il
dirait quoi je pense qu'il serait quand
même très fier de voir l'ampleur de
l'entreprise puis d'avoir qu'on continue
avec un souci de l'entreprise familiale
qu'on veut continuer le travail que lui
avait commencé
grand papa disait c'est pas pour moi que
je fais tout ça c'est pour vous autres
c'est vous autres qui allaient en
profiter et j'espère qu'il trouverait
qu'on en profite bien
[Musique]